So Donald Trump's press secretary, Kaylee
Kennedy, has humiliated herself again, maybe
for the last time if Fox News stops having
her on, although my sense is she'll still
continue humiliating herself for a couple
more months.
Kayleigh McEnany does this thing, which is
completely absurd.
It's absurd and like an evil genius way, which
is she has different personas sometimes.
Kayleigh McEnany is White House press secretary,
speaking in her official role as White House
press secretary.
Sometimes she is a Trump campaign senior adviser
and then sometimes she's just a private person.
And I know that this may be difficult for
a lot of folks who expect logic and reason
to understand.
But when Carly does her press briefings, which
she hasn't done in a very long time, that's
very clear.
She is White House press secretary, very clear
cut, speaking to us as the representative
for Donald Trump.
Now, just before the election, she started
appearing on Fox News pretty frequently under
a different title.
And you would see under her name, it would
say Trump 20 20 senior adviser.
It's already weird because she's officially
a White House staffer.
And then last week at that completely ridiculous
press conference where she said it was all
stolen, Biden didn't win anything.
Trump won everything and held up pieces of
paper.
She said, Hi, I'm Kelly McEnany.
I'm here in my personal capacity.
It's like Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde that that
sort of thing.
Well, this morning, Kelly shows up on Fox
News and you just have to see this.
First of all, I guess, in order to try to
keep things kosher from the standpoint of
the Hatch Act.
Brian Kilmeade actually says Kelly has two
roles.
And today she's here not as press secretary,
but as a campaign person.
Take a look.
Kayleigh McEnany joins us.
She's got a dual role here.
She's on as the Trump 20-20 campaign adviser,
KAIP.
So it's almost like Brian Kilmeade was told.
Make sure to mention this.
And you I mean, I don't know how you tell
the difference.
Maybe when she wears her Diamond Cross necklace,
she's there as press secretary and when she
wears her gold cross necklace, that's when
she's the campaign adviser, sort of like Superman.
When he has the glasses on, it's Clark Kent.
When the glasses come off, it's Superman.
I don't know, but it's all wacky.
But then this is where it gets just beyond
satire.
Brian Kilmeade says, you know, Joe Biden isn't
getting the presidential daily briefing.
He did win.
It's a national security issue.
And Kayleigh says no.
That's a question for the White House.
She is the White House spokesperson as press
secretary.
But today we have to pretend she's a different
character.
She's merely a lowly campaign adviser.
Check this out.
It's wild.
The Republicans say, listen, give Joe Biden
the presidential daily brief.
After all, Senator Harris gets gets she's
on the intel committee.
She's getting she has high, high level security
access.
Has the president consider that.
And I haven't spoken to the president about
that.
That would be a question more for the White
House.
But I will say that all laws are being followed
with regard to an expected transition, though
we expect to continue on as the Trump administration.
And you'll see how our litigation goes when
we say how stupid do they think we are?
They think their followers and Fox News viewers
are very stupid and this is indistinguishable
from parody, and even though we've already
heard that Trump knows he can't win and he's
doing this entire thing as theater and, you
know, taking money from people in doing so.
Kayleigh McEnany will not close the door on
Donald Trump, pushing for Republican legislators
to try to essentially invalidate the election
results by selecting Trump electors.
This is the Electoral College strategy we
talked about about six weeks ago.
And the idea is take a state that Biden won
by the popular vote, like, for example, Wisconsin,
because Biden won.
What they're supposed to do is send Biden
electors to cast their official electoral
votes for Joe Biden.
But if you can find a state with a state legislature
that is Republican that might be willing to
just interfere.
Theoretically, the state legislature could
send Trump electors, even though Joe Biden
wins the popular vote in that state.
That's what they're asking about here.
And Kelly McCann, and he won't rule it out,
controlled state legislatures would then,
because they would not be certified, would
then appoint pro Trump electors who would
swing the Electoral College in his favor.
It's unclear exactly how seriously the campaign
is taking that.
How seriously is the campaign considering
that?
Well, constitutionally, that is an accurate
argument.
It is the state legislatures that choose the
electors.
But right now they're zeroed in completely
on litigation.
And so there she is not ruling it out, but
we might discuss that more.
I've already talked about it.
And of course, no good Trump voter fraud segment
would be complete until somebody holds up
papers for the camera.
And Kayleigh McEnany also doing that extra
ballot.
So we have a number of affidavits from voters
who were not told to fix their ballot while
their Democrat counterparts in seven counties
were.
So that's Kayleigh McEnany, Trump campaign
staffer not there.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
She's White House press secretary.
She wasn't there as White House press secretary.
So when she was asked questions about Trump
that she doesn't want to answer, she says,
oh, that would be a question for the White
House, like maybe for the White House press
secretary, which is her.
These are wild times that we are living through.
I am very ready for it to end.
And we're getting closer.
We're getting closer.
And even Donald Trump seems to be acknowledging
that.